「来たぞー」
「おっしゃー」
「超吸水シェ
「超吸水性樹脂」
「おーっ
うおおっ」
「おおおおっ
おおおおおおっ！」
「これだ！」
「たぶんこれだ」
「ってか絶対これだ」
「これじゃないと無理」
「はい、ついにリベンジする時がやってきました」
「こちら」
「超吸水性樹脂」
「普通のより数百倍もの水を吸収するみたいです」
「というわけで
ついにリベンジする時がやってきた」
「吸収性ポリマーみたいなやつを買ったんですよ」
「水を吸収して膨らむ粉」
「そう思って僕は買ってしまったが」
「んん？」
「全然違った」
「なんかねもう一過程おかないと
水を吸収して膨らむ粉にならなかったみたいなんですけども」
「これはたぶん合ってます」
「絶対そう」
「数百倍の水を吸収できる
不思議な高分子化合物ですって書いてありますから」
「OK、燃えるゴミとして捨てれるんでね」
「頼むよ、マ、マジ頼むよ」
「あの前回の失敗が結構辛くて」
「もうやめようかと思ったんですけど」
「やっぱり見たいじゃないっすか
「粉がさ
粉が水を吸収して膨らむ姿よ」
「ひとつ200グラム入ってるので
2キロ！」
「2キロ分の超吸収性樹脂を準備しました」
「今回こそはやりましょう！」
「これをお風呂にぶち込んで
すごい粉だらけの浴s、あ、待って」
「でもあれだ」
「配管に詰まったらやべえな」
「配管に詰まらないようにしよう」
「とりあえずちょっとこれが本当にそうなるかどうか
っていうのを一回試そう」
「もう失敗は許されないから」
「お前だ！」
「こいつで実験しましょう」
「頼むよ」
「これで膨らまなかったらもうマジやばいよ」
「これで膨らまなかったら俺の股間が膨r」
「じゃあちょっと水をかけてみます」
「あっ、これ膨らまないと坊主になります」
「アバンティーズが」
「いきます！」
「あっあっあっあっあっ
は？」
「膨らんだ」
「膨らんでる膨らんでる」
「膨らんでる膨らんでる！」
「おっ、おー！おっ」
「すごっ、めっちゃ、めっちゃ大きくなった！」
「めっちゃ巨大化してます」
「うわっ」
「あっ」
「食べないほうがいいかも」
「すごい　ゼリーみたいに大きくなりました」
「いける！いける！いける！」
「お風呂場にいきましょう！」
「いけるいける！！」
「こんにちは！Dr.はじめだ」
「いよいよ超吸水性樹脂」
「こちらを使って」
「水を…」
〈ピピ〉
「え？」
「最低でも」
「百倍の重量になると言うことなので」
「吸水性樹脂を」
「2kg準備しているので」
「簡単に計算すると…」
「　約にひゃくｇ　」
「魔法の粉が」
「どれまで大きくなるかと言う実験だ」
「まぁ、書いてある通り」
「水道の」
「配管に捨てちゃ」
「ダメなので」
「バッチリ全てロックしてあります」
「では、さっそく粉を入れていこう」
「もうシンプルにいれますよ」
「うわぁ…」
「うわ、まって粉シーンこなこなこな」
「うぅわぁ」
「エッホンッ（咳き込む声」
「ア”ァ”」
「あんま、吸い込まない方がいい系かも」
「はい、と言うわけで」
「約2kgの魔法の粉」
「入りました」
「はい、バッチリ入っております」
「はい！というわけで」
「準備の方バッチリでございます！」
「はたして、水を百倍以上吸収する」
「不思議な粉は、」
「2kgあると」
「どれくらいの質量になるのか」
〈水を出しています〉
「さあ、今入りました」
「うわ！」
「すげぇ！」
「あ、もう固まってきてる！」
「固まってきてる」
「うおぉ、すげすげすげぇ！」
「まだここらへん」
「全然粉なんで、」
「わかる？」
「あああ！あぶねぇ！！」
「あっ」
「落とす所だった・・・！」
「うわぁもう全然塊だ」
「ちょっといい感じなので」
「もうちょっと待ってみましょう」
「目は危なくなかったね」
「ほら！凄い！」
「もうゼリーみたいになっちゃってる」
「うわすげ」
「全然水を吸収します」
「そして」
「どんどん大きくなっていっております」
「はたしてこの粉は」
「どこまで膨らむのでしょうか！」
「まだいけるぞ！！！」
♪～
「ハッ…ハッハハッ（乾いた笑い声」
〈ドゴンッ〉
「一応水ではないので」
「まだ、かろうじて吸収はしているみたいです」
「オラァァ！」
「オラオラオラァ！」
「これまだ、吸収できるんじゃね？」
「これさ、まだ」
「硬いところがあるから」
「たぶんまだ水を吸収できるなお前ら？」
「なぁ！？」
超吸水性樹脂「　ソウダヨ　」
〈投げ捨てる音〉
「ちょっと、限界まで水を吸水させてみましょう」
「おおおおおおお！」
「すーげぇ」
「オラァー」
「重い！」
「はい、というわけで」
「水を吸収する不思議な粉」
「2kgに水を足した結果」
「全然吸収します」
「たぶん２００ｋ超えてる重さです」
「おぉすごい」
「いやーすげーななんか」
「ゼリー風呂に入ってる気分です」
「片づけどうしょう…」
♪～